I don't belong here
fans are so excited for Toy Story for
trying to piece together these teasers
what can you tell the fans I can tell
you that gosh darn it I don't know what
to say because every time I do this to
get in trouble both Tom and I who met
yesterday for our little guy lunch had
we both very very affected by the end of
the movie so much so that he had to we
said the same thing he had to turn
around he couldn't even deliver his end
of it I couldn't deliver my end of it
it's a wonderful full bodied movie
they've taken this in a direction that
is spectacular but not you go oh that I
can't believe I haven't thought of that
before these writers have done something
amazing the characters they develop are
amazing it's a love story between Tom
and his love interest but he's a toy I
mean it is what it is and then buzz has
to make a decision on how to move on
with his life because it's a Tom's
making some differences at Woody's
making some different decisions and
that's all I can tell you I'm just
saying that it's so funny and so bright
and so interesting and so effective
towards the end I don't want this to be
the last choice story is there a chance
we could get Toy Story 5 you got a guy
talking Tom doesn't think so he and I he
said we have a lunch that we got where
he said this has been over 20 years of
he and I doing this and I said yeah and
it's made an impact on both of our lives
and our family's lives I don't I think
it's like Harry Potter my kids right
into that now my little one and I said
that did like 300 movies or wide it was
a lot
there's once you've gotten to four you
foster your past that trilogy I don't
see any reason why they wouldn't do any
every service certainly if you asked me
I'd say do five
you